in this lesson we're going to talk about
nonverbal behavior paying particular
attention to the expressions of emotion
now there are many types of nonverbal
behaviors gazing hugging touching
smiling and grooming are only but a few
of many many more
often times these behaviors are
associated with specific emotions or
used to communicate those specific
emotions
in order to clarify which non-verbal
behaviors are related to which emotions
paul ekman and wallace friesen organized
nonverbal behaviors into five different
categories
the first category is called an emblem
emblems are nonverbal gestures that
directly translate into words and have
specific meanings within a culture for
english speakers this includes the
thumbs up the peace sign and in the late
1960s to raise and clench fist to
indicate black power in the united
states
the important thing to note with emblems
is that no words are required for them
to convey their meaning their message is
sent with the gesture alone
i alluded to this before but it is
important to note that emblems vary
across cultures significantly
there are some emblems that have a
meaning in one culture and no meaning in
another culture
to make matters even more confusing or
prone to miscommunication there are some
emblems that have a meaning in one
culture and a different meaning in
another culture
for example the thumbs up gesture means
good job or okay in america however the
same gesture means up yours in middle
eastern countries
the second category is called
illustrators
illustrators are non-verbal gestures
that accompany and embellish our speech
they differ from emblems in that they
don't have any specific meaning without
the words they accompany
examples include the eyebrow races that
emphasize a specific point and the
conductor-like hand and arm movements
that i'm doing as i spontaneously speak
now
for example this motion doesn't have any
specific meaning unless i'm telling you
that i'm talking about waves in an ocean
the next category is called regulators
regulators are non-verbal behaviors that
are used to coordinate conversations and
interactions
for example head nods and eyebrow
flashes can be used to emphasize
specific portions of speech
regulators also include orienting our
bodies towards and away from people to
suggest turn-taking during conversations
it should be noted that these non-verbal
behaviors come naturally to us they are
the behaviors that we all know but have
never been explicitly taught to us
the fourth category is manipulators or
adapters
these are actions that as the name
implies manipulate parts of our bodies
these include scratching rubbing picking
and other similar behaviors
the last category of nonverbal behaviors
is emotional expressions or displays of
affect
not surprisingly we're going to spend
most of our time talking about these
emotional expressions are patterns of
behavior in the face voice body and
touch that convey internal emotional
states
the definition of emotional expressions
begs the question
how can one distinguish between a
genuine expression of an emotion or
feigned expression of an emotion
well there are three different ways
first expressions of emotion tend to
last just a few seconds
in contrast other expressive behaviors
can be very brief or last for longer
periods of time
for example a genuine smile typically
lasts between four to six seconds a
social or fain smile may either be
exceptionally brief lasting only a
quarter of a second or endure for a long
period of time that is lasting the
duration of an entire conversation
second emotional expressions involve
involuntary muscle actions
people have a hard time deliberately
producing these in the absence of an
emotion and a difficult time suppressing
them in the presence of an emotion
we'll talk much more about this later
finally genuine emotional expressions
have been found to unfold over time
differently than famed expressions
more specifically emotional expressions
have a more fluid onset and offset in
comparison to feigned emotional
expressions
now one question you might be asking is
are these facial expressions universal
that is do they exist in the same way
across all cultures in the world
if these facial expressions are
universal that would be strong evidence
to suggest that they are not solely
culturally determined
the logic is as follows if facial
expressions of emotions are 100
culturally determined then you'd expect
that with all the thousands of different
cultures out there that the facial
expressions would vary by culture
however if facial expressions are
universal then there must be something
more than culture that plays a role in
determining them
darwin hypothesized that facial
expressions were universal he had two
specific hypotheses
the first was the encoding hypothesis
the encoding hypothesis stated that the
experience of different emotions should
be associated with the same distinct
expressions in every culture
the second was the decoding hypothesis
the decoding hypothesis stated that
people in different cultures should
interpret facial expressions in the same
way
to test these hypotheses paul ekman and
wallace friesen traveled to papua new
guinea and lived with the people of the
foray language group
these people were unique in that at
least at the time of ekman and frieza's
visit in the 1960s they had no exposure
to western culture
that is they had seen no movies read no
books or magazines and did not speak
english
this strong cultural difference allowed
for a valid measurement of whether
people encode and decode emotions in the
same ways across cultures
ekman and friesen brought over 3000
photographs of people expressing anger
disgust fear happiness sadness and
surprise according to darwin's
descriptions
they then devised brief stories that
corresponded to each of these six
emotions
for example the story corresponding to
the sad expression was the person's
child had died and he felt sad
then they presented photos of three
different expressions with the story
that matched one of the expressions and
asked participants to match the story
with one of three expressions
this was a test of the decoding
hypothesis
in another task ekman and friesen
videotaped the foray participants as
they displayed facial expressions
displayed in response to the
emotion-specific story
they then presented these videotapes to
undergraduate students in the united
states and asked them to select from six
emotion charts the one that best matched
the fourier's pose
this was a test of the encoding
hypothesis
ekman and friesen found that the foray
participants accurately judged the
proper emotions corresponding to the
facial expressions
this served as evidence of the encoding
hypothesis
they also found that college students
from the united states correctly
interpreted the posed expressions of the
videotaped foray participants
this is evidence of the decoding
hypothesis
taken together these findings constitute
strong evidence for the universality of
facial expressions of emotion
now i would be remiss if i did not say
that these findings were not without
criticism
in fact the word remiss is certainly an
understatement because these findings
and the critique of these findings have
created a long-standing debate among
emotion researchers
here are a few of the main critiques
the first was in regard to the response
format that ekman and friesen chose to
use
they used a forced choice technique that
asked participants to label facial
expressions using a set of terms that
the researchers provided
it is possible that this inflated the
accuracy of participants judgments
because there were only a select few
possible choices
an open-ended response style would have
solved this problem though it would have
been much more difficult to interpret
the results
the second main critique revolves around
the ecological validity of the
expressions that ekman and friesen used
their expressions portrayed images that
were static highly stylized and
exaggerated
although these images provided clear
examples of the expressed emotion they
may not have been reflective of the more
nuanced expressions that occurred during
natural discourse
finally ekman and friesen had been
criticized for only using a limited
number of emotions
for example there was only one positive
emotion and no self-conscious emotions
such as embarrassment shame or guilt
despite this controversy facial
expressions of emotion have been shown
to reveal a great deal of information
regarding internal emotional and
motivational states
just by looking at the face you can tell
what emotion is being expressed
happiness sadness anger fear disgust and
contempt for example all have
characteristic facial expressions of
emotion
you can also tell the intensity of an
emotion
by attending to the intensity of the
muscular contractions you can
differentiate between a little bit of
trepidation to outright terror and
between a little bit of annoyance to
outright rage
you can also tell if two emotions are
blended together so you can
differentiate between surprise and
happiness like when i see my best friend
after a long time or surprise and
disgust like when i see a cockroach
all this information can be gleaned
simply by looking at the face something
that is so conspicuous that it can't be
inconspicuously hidden
now the face is what we call a dual
processing system
that means that the face is capable of
producing both spontaneous genuine
expressions of emotion as well as
deliberate feigned expressions of
emotion what this means is that although
people who study facial expression
promotion like me see it as having more
veracity than self-report we don't
actually believe that the smiling flight
attendant is happy to see us
it turns out that the rabbit hole goes
even deeper
spontaneous and deliberate facial
expressions emanate from separate upper
motor neuron pathways
deliberately induced movements emanate
from the cortical motor strip where
spontaneously induced movements emanate
from the phylogenetically older
extrapyramidal motor system
if you have damage to the cortical motor
strip you'll lose the ability to make a
facial expression on command but retain
the ability to make a spontaneous facial
expression
on the other hand if you have damage to
the exoparameter motor system you'll
lose the ability to make a spontaneous
facial expression but retain the ability
to make a facial expression on command
i know this image is difficult to
picture but consider someone who has
damage to their cortical motor strip
leaving them hemi-paralyzed on the
anatomical left side of their face
importantly this hemi paralysis is only
present for deliberately induced facial
movements
on the left side consider an individual
responding to a directed facial action
task in which he is instructed to smile
here he's only able to express this on
the anatomic right side of his face
on the right side picture the same
individual responding to a stimulus that
generally produces positive emotion
note that in this spontaneous task he is
able to recruit the exact same muscles
that he was not able to innervate in the
deliberate facial action task
furthermore it turns out that not all
facial muscles are equally able to be
controlled
there are specific facial muscles that
paul ekman termed reliable facial
muscles
these facial muscles have a specific
property
that is fewer than 10 to 15 percent of
individuals can do these two things
the first is to contract these muscles
in the absence of an emotion and the
second is to suppress these muscles in
the presence of an emotion
these reliable facial muscles include
those that are present in many of the
basic emotions
they include the inner eyebrow razor
most people can raise their inner
eyebrow concurrently with their outer
eyebrow however very few people can
raise their inner eyebrow independently
from their outer eyebrow unless they are
genuinely feeling fearful
they also include the lip corner
depressor which pulls the lip corners
downward in sadness
interestingly many fake this action by
raising their chin boss which is
detectably different
there is a video clip of staff sergeant
ryan pitts receiving a medal from
president barack obama in 2014.
at this moment obama says something that
would make the adolescent boy in all of
us chuckle
he says something along the lines of up
at their tiny post ryan and his team
were being pounded
if you look closely you can see that
sergeant pitts smiles slightly before
voluntarily counteracting the upward
polar lip corner with other facial
muscles
this has always been fascinating to me
because it highlights our inability to
control our facial expressions
completely
more specifically if sergeant pitts was
able to stop a smile he would have
the fact that he has to recruit
additional muscles to counteract the
smile suggested he cannot simply stop
the muscles associated with the smile
from contracting
this is what antonio dimaggio called
controlling the uncontrollable he said
and i quote
we are about as effective at stopping an
emotion as we are preventing a sneeze we
can try to prevent the expression of
emotion and we may succeed in part but
not in full end quote
so taken together we have seen that the
face reveals a great deal of information
and that facial expressions are
difficult to fake
but why
why are emotions so intimately tied to
our faces and the way that we move them
asked in a different way
what's the benefit of honestly
advertising something as personal
subjective and intimate as your own
emotional and motivational states
someplace as conspicuous as the face
again a place so conspicuous that it's
hard to inconspicuously hide it
wouldn't it be better to just keep your
emotional states private wouldn't a
poker face be better
wouldn't the proverbial smell of fear
just egg on our opponents
now
the benefit to the person who sees the
facial expression is clear
that person gets accurate information
regarding the signalers emotional state
which is tied to their action tendencies
but based off of evolutionary theory and
signaling theory there needs to be a
benefit to the signaler or the facial
expresser him or herself
this is a question that i put forth a
lot of effort in studying and i think
we've got some good answers
one of the answers might be that facial
expressions serve to advertise
subjective commitments
there are class of problems that the
economist thomas shelling called
commitment problems
let me give you a few examples
a kidnapper suddenly gets cold feet
he wants to set his victim free but he's
afraid that his victim will go to the
police if he does
in return for his freedom the victim
gladly promises that he'll never go to
the police
the problem is this
both the kidnapper and the victim
realize that it will no longer be in the
victim's interest to keep this promise
once the victim is set free
so the kidnapper reluctantly concludes
that he has to kill the victim
how might you solve this problem
well here's one solution
if the victim has committed an act whose
disclosure could lead to blackmail he
might confess it
if not he might commit one in the
presence of the kidnapper to create a
bond that will ensure the victim's
silence
perhaps the victim could allow the
kidnapper to photograph him or her in
the process of some unspeakably
degrading or embarrassing act
the threat of blackmail hero serves as a
commitment device
a commitment device is something that
provides the victim with an incentive to
keep his or her promise after they've
been set free
surely opening up the threat of black
men will certainly be unpleasant for the
victim once he or she is freed but
clearly less so than not being able to
make a credible promise in the first
place and being killed
these types of commitment devices are
everywhere and they work just as well
when they commit ourselves to specific
actions as they are when they commit
others to specific actions
for example the best way to make sure
that you actually get up on time is to
voluntarily place your alarm clock on
the other side of the room
the best way to make sure that you won't
be late is to set your clock five
minutes fast
there are even computer and phone apps
that commit us to not wasting our time
using our cellular phones
here's another interpersonal example
let's say that you have two persons
named smith and jones
smith and jones can engage in a
potentially profitable venture let's say
opening up a restaurant
their potential gain arises from the
natural advantages inherent in the
division and specialization of labor
smith is a talented cook but is shy and
an incompetent manager
jones on the other hand cannot boil an
egg but is charming and has shrewd
business judgment
together they have the necessary skills
to launch a successful venture
working alone however their potential is
much more limited
the problem in this situation is that
each person will have opportunities to
cheat without the possibility of being
detected
smith can take kickbacks from food
suppliers and jones can skim the cash
drawer without smith's knowledge
if one of them cheats the cheater does
very well however the non-cheater does
poorly and cannot be sure why
the low return from the restaurant is
not a reliable sign as having been
cheated since there are many benign
explanations for why a business might do
poorly
if the victim also cheats he too can
escape detection and will do better by
cheating
this problem could be solved in the same
way as the kidnapper problem
if both smith and jones could make a
binding commitment not to cheat then
their partner would be happy to enter
into the cooperative venture with them
and they would both profit by doing so
as an economist and philosopher one of
adam smith's most enduring contributions
is his idea of moral sentiments
moral sentiments are emotions such as
anger contempt disgust envy greed shame
and guilt
smith argued that these sentiments
function by competing with calculations
stemming from rational self-interest
and it is for exactly this reason that
they can help people solve commitment
problems
consider a person capable of strong
feelings of guilt
this person will not cheat on their
partner even when it is in their
material interest to do so not because
he or she fears being caught but simply
because he or she doesn't want to cheat
the aversion to feelings of guilt
effectively alters the payoffs that he
or she faces
that is they know that cheating will
bring on awful feelings of guilt which
are so averse that they will deter the
individual from cheating in the first
place
now consider the person who becomes
enraged when dealt with unjustly
this person doesn't need a formal
contract to seek revenge they're going
to seek revenge because they want to
even when in purely material terms it
does not pay
here the feelings of anger offset their
material interests
the good feelings of exacting vengeance
altered the payoffs that he or she faces
that is they know that exacting revenge
on the people who have dealt with them
unjustly motivate them to seek revenge
even when they have nothing to gain
now
the good feelings that we get by
remaining faithful to our partners and
by exacting revenge on the people who
have caused harm to us are in a very
real sense their own reward
but we are living in a material world a
world of material payoffs and for these
sentiments to be viable that is for them
to have evolved via evolution by natural
selection they must have yielded some
material payoff
let's take guilt for example
the potential gain of not cheating on
your partner is to motivate them to
engage in the cooperative venture with
you
not cheating is counterproductive after
the fact
let's take the example of revenge
a desire to seek revenge is
counterproductive after the fact
what good is it proving to someone now
that they should not have harmed you
then
so it's not enough for us to have these
subjective commitments they have to be
honestly communicated for them to incur
a benefit
and that is why we express them on our
faces
this idea is no better expressed than in
this 1971 comic from the new yorker
magazine
here you have a couple walking down the
street who needs to decide whether or
not to buy a pencil from the
extortionist who is carrying a
collections box and a whip
if they believe the extortion is to be a
rational person then the whip doesn't
matter there's no way that a rational
person would risk a jail sentence for a
few added pencil sales
however if they believe the extortion is
to be an irrational person then it is in
their self-interest to buy a pencil
whether they want one or not
notice here that it isn't the sign
around his neck that lets them know that
he's not rational that sign can be
easily fixed
what lets them know for sure is a look
on his face
a look that expresses an emotion that he
did not decide to have and cannot decide
not to have
this idea provides an explanation for
why emotions are so intimately tied to
the body
it has been proposed independently by
the economist thomas schelling the
evolutionary psychologist robert trivers
martin daley and margot wilson and the
economists robert frank and jack
hirschlifer
it goes by several names the most common
are the dooms in machine theory the
theory of mutually assured destruction
and the frank hirschlifer hypothesis
my colleagues and i have tested this
hypothesis over the past several years
in these studies we have found that
smiles honestly signal a commitment to
behave cooperatively towards others
angry expressions honestly signal a
commitment to behave spitefully towards
others
sadness expressions honestly signaled
the need for help and fearful
expressions honestly signal the presence
of danger
each of these studies has demonstrated
that people respond to these expressions
differently in comparison to a neutral
expression
taken together with a theory that i just
described they strongly suggest that
facial expressions honestly advertise
subjective commitments
this idea makes sense intuitively
one day i went into the fabric store to
get a frame for a radiohead poster i'd
purchased at a concert
i went up to the register and was
prepared to lay down the 100 or so
dollars for the frame
however the cashier to my surprise told
me that there was a sale and the frame
was 50 off
the store giving me the frame for 50 off
at this point was clearly not in their
self-interest
i was going to buy the frame anyways and
was prepared to give them the full price
the whole point of a sale is to get
people to buy things that they might not
normally buy at full price
it's a commitment
but like the subjective commitments that
we've talked about before it's useless
after the fact and needs to be honestly
advertised to benefit the person willing
to make the commitment
this is why sales are so ubiquitously
advertised both before and during the
time they are being held
so we've talked about non-verbal
behavior in general and facial
expressions of emotion in particular
i also presented a theory that explains
why emotions are expressed on the face
and in the body
if you're interested in learning more
about this i would highly recommend the
1988 book by robert frank called
passions within reason or the edited
volume by randy nessie called evolution
and the capacity for commitment
here we discuss the expressions of
emotions and the ways that others can be
conscious of them
in the next lecture we'll talk about the
self-conscious emotions that we are
inherently aware of in ourselves
[Music]
you